[Music]
Oh
I was always interested in understanding
how one thing wins our attention
compared to other so you can think of
walking in the street there are many
things that you see there's there's
sounds there's smells and somehow only
one thing better train to your
consciousness and become a world like if
you walk on the street you guys see
everything they see trees and they see
cars they see houses but somehow in your
mind you focus on only one thing why is
that how does your brain decide that
this information is going to be more
dominant than anything else the second
of competition occurring in your brain
between all the images any life we are
always a face who is with competing
stimuli with competing distractions and
we eventually are thinking about one
thing at a time how do we do that this
particular study was done in a group of
neurological patients undergoing brain
surgery for severe intractable epilepsy
that cannot be treated successfully with
medications and the key challenge in
this patient is to identify an area in
the brain where potentially the seizures
are coming from so that later this area
can be resected in surgery with the high
probability of cure now the way this is
done is that the patient undergo an
implantation of specific electrodes that
are placed in the brain in particular
targets which are suspected to be the
origin of the the seizures they sit
essentially on a ward in the hospital
for several days awaiting the seizure to
occur
[Music]
this is a very unique opportunity to be
able to record not just the EEG but
actually the defying of individual nerve
cells we can listen in on the
conversation that neurons have with with
each other so we try to make the most of
this incredible very opportunity by
asking the patient to play a simple
video game in which they can use their
thoughts to control what they see on a
computer monitor in front of them we
have seen in the past that there are
particular brain cells which are able to
represent information in a very abstract
fashion meaning that if you have got
some stimulus in the environment in
pinching on the retina by the time it
comes to our nerve cells in the medial
temporal lobe it is encoded in an
abstract fashion meaning that if you are
thinking now of Marilyn Monroe that
particular neuron in your brain and
probably a group of other neurons like
this particular neurons they come to
life with a particular memory or even
the imagery of Marilyn Monroe
[Music]
and in this project we wanted to see how
speedily and selectively people can
modulate he's the anneal activity of
these neurons in their own head my own
serve developed a fancy feedback
technique that allows him to visualize a
flying activity or four more neurons in
a patient head using a movie the way he
does it is that he finds one neuron that
the response selectively much most only
let's say to Marilyn Monroe then two
images of josh olin we find the differ a
second neuron that responds much more to
josh brolin than two images of Marilyn
Monroe want you to see how their patient
in their own mind can really sum on up
one thought on the expense perhaps of
another thought and that was done in
here in a way that the particular
thought that they had it could be
depicted on a a screen so then the
paradigm essentially starts with a
fusion or a hybrid of two different
concept let's say Marilyn Monroe and
Josh Brolin so you essentially start
with with the hybrid and then by a
controlling your thought process you can
in a sense change the balance between
those two representations now on the
screen you basically can very quickly
learn how to bring in one image on the
expense of another
[Music]
as strong at the jaws Paulo neon fires
the more you see the image of George
Boleyn and the more the image of the
Malley Monroe will fade that it's a
competition if the patient attends more
to Marilyn Monroe the murli manohar unit
will hopefully fire stronger and will
enhance each movies a unique function of
the firing rate of of these neurons each
new really expresses how well how
quickly how strongly patients can
control their neurons using nothing but
their thoughts in a conscious manner
the patient would then in in his or her
own mind create a situation where those
neurons responsible for Marilyn Monroe
would essentially take over the neurons
which are responsible for Josh Brolin
meaning not only that the neurons of
Marilyn Monroe would suddenly come to
life actively but those other neurons
representing Josh Brolin would simply go
down in their activity or essentially be
inhibited incidentally this research
also answers the questions of how do you
suppress how do you not think of a white
elephant well the answer is you do that
by partly partially suppressing the
responses of the neurons that encode the
white elephant it remarkable for the
patients that they sit in bed and they
didn't know anything about this thing
they didn't know that they can access
their neurons a minute before we started
but now they get direct access to the
neurons in their brain they sit there
and they're kind of fascinated by the
ability to move things on the screen
voluntarily just by pure fault
so one of the remarkable result of the
paper is that the situations that I
should actually see on the screen one
thing but I've told to think of
something else so you see a picture of a
spider on the screen almost entirely but
we told them your target is Larry below
so they come here and they're able to
win the trial by thinking of Melanie and
overriding the visual inputs update
their eyes see a spider but their mind
thinks may not know and those two
concepts out kind of competing inside
their brain but because the mind is
stronger than the vision they somehow
able to override this vision in with the
toy by making each other memory appear
on the screen the environment offers a
lot of information to us and it's all
kind of being read by our senses when we
see things we smell things when we
listen to things they all get into our
brain but we choose what to attend to so
this in a sense brings the question is
who is really in control do we control
our neurons or do our neurons control us
of course the solution may be that we
ourselves are our own neurons but that a
study essentially manifested our ability
to override the sensory input by a
voluntary process what our results
clearly show is that at least in these
structures particular in the hippocampus
in their ParaPro kampl cortex thought
overrides external realities here at
least idealism council realism then
maybe in the future ability to develop
brain machine interfaces switch on base
and human thought on human intention on
human imagery on human memory or even on
human dreams
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]